hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my walking dead goat simulator
video seriously though the biggest
surprise this week was that we're not
following up with Glenn we're actually
getting a deep dive into the craziest
person ever Morgan just careful for goat
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet and new round of the giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's a $20 Amazon gift card you
can totally use it to buy food for
Tabitha may she rest in peace so let's
just get into it starting with top 5 WTF
number 5 this is a full-blown 90 minute
Morgan episode we start with him in
present-day talking to that wolf that we
don't get the reveal till the end of the
episode but he is narrating his
experience of how he became Jedi Morgan
all about eastman the person who taught
him how to quote/unquote walk through
the door which it turns out that the
goat was smarter than him I loved that
the goat was able to do what Morgan was
not opened the door you had to tell me
that I could open the door before I knew
that it was open so Tabitha won Morgan
zero and of course the goat being
smarter ends up being the one that the
show kills off that's one of the worst
things you could be on The Walking Dead
one of the smarter characters anytime
there's a crutch for the group like
somewhere you can get cheese from on
demand there's no way the writers are
gonna let that last but the actual intro
was one of the best intros that The
Walking Dead has had all year long it's
just that I feel like the episode didn't
need to be 90 minutes I would have been
totally happy if they would have broken
this story up into a couple different
pieces but part of me wonders if they
sold Lennie James on coming back to the
show because they were gonna give him
this episode like they knew they would
do a special Morgan episode so they're
like come be a regular in series 6 we'll
give you this awesome 90 minute episode
all by itself and he actually said
during talking dead that Episode four
was a complete secret from the rest of
the cast they showed up to episode like
five or six and then went back and shot
episode 4 I'm not really sure why they
needed to keep it a secret though I'm
not sure what the reasoning is there
because because there weren't any
spoilers in here like we just get more
against backstory it's not like they're
spoiling what ends up happening to the
characters in the future I think they
maybe just wanted it to be something
special but I feel like most of us
tonight we're like screaming at the
beginning of the episode when we
realized that Glenn wasn't going to be
in it they weren't gonna follow up with
that it's like everyone makes like their
oh Jesus clintus oh oh my god when they
realized that he's not gonna be in it
we're not gonna get to see whether or
not he made under that dumpster and yes
I have seen all of the glens spoilers I
know but you know there's something
going on with that character maybe
you've seen the spoilers maybe you
haven't but the question has already
been answered as to what's going on with
him just in case you don't want to know
I'm not gonna post them here if you want
to talk about him just please use
spoiler tags but I know number four
Morgan must clear this is the greatest
thing in the world it's like the
greatest circular logic that he has in
his head this is when he's still in
crazy mode which by the way is this
really awesome camera effect it's like
this vignette inking they created where
the camera gets really fuzzy around the
edges it's like when Morgan goes into
Terminator mode so I'm hoping they bring
it back at some point in the future like
in some future episode if he's forced to
kill someone and it just goes over the
edge he goes back into this Terminator
mode but clear was a big theme in this
episode it's a reminder of the season 3
episode clear like the episode that was
titled clear where Morgan's like
literally stuck his brain is stuck in
that time even though his body continues
moving forward like Eastman said there's
a door that you keep going to it keeps
taking you back to that place so now
you're not trying to go through the door
anymore so he's like frozen in that time
during that season 3 moment that's why
when he was strangling this kid here I
kept thinking about that moment where he
was trying to kill Rick like he was
reliving that in his mind but you could
also argue that because Morgan thought
this was like a father-son pair that he
thought he was killing himself in his
own son
Dwayne like he was reliving that but all
I could think when Eastman was
questioning him about the meaning of
clear like why do you have to clear and
he said I cleared because I'm still here
and I'm still here because I clear so
it's like this circular logic that he's
stuck in on the number 3 Morgan
vs. Eastman so he's been tells Morgan
that he could have left at any time the
door is open he slips back into
Terminator mode and rushes the [ __ ] out
of him
I love Eastman's reaction when he sees
Morgan going for the the fire pokers and
just goes [ __ ]
but the only point where Eastman
actually gets pissed is when Morgan
smashes his daughters drawing is that so
later in the episode that we learned the
significance of that how he literally
walked like 30 miles for a piece of dry
wood and he says as he's he's sitting
there dying it's the best decision I
ever made but they have it out like he's
loli brings Morgan back to life teaches
em Aikido become become says Yoda
there's even like a swap nearby so you
can make every Star Wars joke that you
want to make but it all breaks down the
minute Morgan is forced to go back to
his past like he's forced to go back
through the door to relive that moment
again in that campsite
sometimes when the Walking Dead does
visual metaphors it's really obvious
sometimes it's a little harder to see
but they kept talking about walking
through the door going back to
quote-unquote
that moment that's what that campsite
was that's what that represented so he
walked back he was forced to see the
child again so it's almost like he was
hallucinating Duane again and it just
all just goes to [ __ ] Eastman ends up
getting bitten and Morgan completely
regresses but then kind of quickly
rebounds on the number two though
Eastman explains the story about the
serial killer that killed his family he
tells Morgan most of it but then he
stops short and doesn't finish till he's
getting ready to die and he tells Morgan
I brought him back here
I watched him starve to death it took 47
days in fact I only learned about the
apocalypse when I went back to Atlanta
to turn myself in this is probably one
of the best character backstories that
I've heard from someone that was not a
main character that I mean that this
Eastman person is just a one-off deal
you could argue that it's kind of
contrived that Morgan needing someone
like Eastman happens to run into Eastman
who is totally Zen and has all the
skills necessary to rehabilitate Morgan
I think what happened to Daryl Dixon is
a little bit more realistic like I mean
this is the apocalypse terrible people
survive you would probably bump into the
claimers instead of someone like Eastman
like even Morgan as he hits the road
again after Eastman's like you know
everything you need is here but you
shouldn't stay here he sees the terminus
sign at the tracks and heads towards it
so naturally like he is heading towards
something awful that feels more
authentic but if there was any confusion
that was the moment we saw him at the
very end of season 5 episode 1 like this
this episode went right up to that
moment but finally on to my very obvious
number one WTF moment
Morgan is secretly keeping this wolf
locked up inside the safe zone this is
where the show gets really obvious very
literal with the conflict it's
presenting us with Morgan is being
challenged with the idea that all life
is sacred but there's this wolf here
that says that his code tells him that
he has
to kill everyone even the children you
said it yourself don't be sorry for
anything so very clearly either Morgan
or someone else is going to have to kill
him
like there's no way this is gonna end
well he's gonna get out kill somebody
else Morgan's gonna regret it he'll
still end up dying and then Morgan will
have this on his conscience so here's my
big question for you guys
two big possibilities either we're gonna
get to watch the fall of Jedi Morgan as
he goes to the dark side and starts
killing again
or this wolf is gonna kill a bunch of
people and then someone else is gonna
kill them which do you think is going to
happen I think it'd be a lot more
thrilling to see Morgan go to the dark
side but I think something we'll be able
to save him I think they want Morgan's
story to be a hopeful one even though
Walking Dead is this super bloody drama
like you're made to feel bad about
yourself but every once in a while you
get these moments of hope I think that
Morgan is meant to be a moment of hope
amongst the very crazy rest of the cast
especially given what happened to Glenn
last week so just remind her about where
we are on the timeline we're still right
at the end of that moment where rick is
trapped in the RV Glenn is stuck inside
that pile of walkers and then Abraham
Sasha and Daryl are trying to lead the
super pack away so I think next week
we'll pick right back up where that left
off congratulations to Claire slate
you're the winner of last week's Walking
Dead giveaway is a $20 Amazon gift card
just private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact
info and thank you for nominating me to
go on talking dead even though I think
that would be a total disaster for
everyone involved it sounds like it'd be
a lot of fun and Chris Hardwick and I
both work for legendary so we'll see
maybe someday and if you didn't see it
they actually they dropped the trailer
for preacher if you don't know what that
is is a supernatural comic book series
kind of in the vein of Hellblazer but
that's gonna be premiering soon I don't
know if I'll have time to do videos for
it but I'll at least do a trailer video
for it because Dominic Cooper is awesome
and it looks like it's gonna be a lot of
fun so white guys wait for all that
stuff to post you can click here for the
arrow Constantine trailer I just posted
and you can click here for my Glen video
from last week just so just to relive
the horror again thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight